salut santiago quelques jours une vidéo
je vous parlais de l'asus zen fold 500
est dur à prononcer à jay z
s'il le prononcer très rapidement je
dévore c'est un petit peu la galère un
smartphone donc j'ai fait effectivement
une vidéo de unboxing et ce à quelques
jours et maintenant on a posé la
question est-ce que ce asus iphone 5 z
est un bon smartphone et ce qui vaut le
coup est-ce qu'il faut se positionner au
delà du design très attrayant au delà du
fait qu'il est bien finie que le dos ne
prend pas particulièrement trop traces
de doigts qu'il est plutôt bien fait que
l'écran est agréable comme ça à première
vue est-ce que ce a vu cinq à zelten 5z
est ce qui vous le poète il faut
l'acheter ou alors est-ce qu'il faut
passer son tour
on y va
de la famille asus je veux le plus haut
de gamme des iphone 5 le jeune fan 5z un
smartphone qui franchement sur le papier
vaut vraiment le coup
qualcomm snapdragon 845 6 ou 8 gigas de
ram 64 ou 128 go de stockage que l'on
peut monter jusqu'à 2 des rats un dos
avec un effet miroir un capteur
d'empreintes digitales
ici ils reconnaissance faciale qui est
extrêmement rapide
un écran de 6,2 pouces c'est une dalle
ips1 fhd plus 2246 par 1080 pixels
alors est-ce que ce asus eee phone 5z
vaut le coup oui ou non on va détailler
ça tout de suite
vous êtes bel et bien une bête dali ps
qui occupent 90 % de la face avant
vous avez un verre en corning gorilla
glass strong solide et vous avez aussi
un filtre anti lumières bleues donc ça
c'est plutôt bien pensé
comme je le dis dans la vidéo donne
boxing le seul coin de rue et qu'on peut
avoir sur ce smartphone cette petite
bande noire et franchement vu le prix
faut vraiment aimer râler pour aller
chercher un point défaut ici je trouve
que vraiment le smartphone est vraiment
bien conçu je le dis une fois de plus le
dos et une vraie belle réussite qui
donne un côté extrêmement premium je
vous conseille néanmoins d'enlever cette
petite partie là parce que ça gâche un
peu le plaisir c'est parce qu'elle plus
joli en faire un petit test pour youtube
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour poser une
question qui a eu l'idée de chercher
monsieur gros tatouage sur youtube si
c'est vous dénoncez vous directement aux
commentaires ça m'intéresse lorsque vous
les vidéos sur youtube ou paix
complètement zoom et profitez de votre
grand écran côté positif les bords sont
assez équilibrés un peu plus des
bordures à gauche un peu moins de
bordures à droite
néanmoins vous n'allez pas avoir
l'encoche qui va venir vous renier une
partie ici mais c'est aussi ce qui lui
confère un côté négatif par rapport à
certains autres modèles soient marché
vous allez encore plus de pouvoir zoomer
dans l'image
après je suis fondamentalement pas
extrêmement convaincu de cette idée de
pouvoir retrouver parce que lorsque vous
zoomez vous allez perdre un petit peu
début de la vidéo et du coup vous allez
pouvoir perdre des informations que
créateur a voulu vous donner en temps de
jeu je trouve plutôt pas mal assez
fluide ça fonctionne bien
là je suis pas particulièrement un
excellent joueur très très bon pour
jouer au foot mais bon pourquoi pas en
attendant je trouve que ça fonctionne
bien ça fait 2 sauf l affaire forcément
qu'un qualcomm snapdragon 845 ça ne peut
que fall à faire au niveau de l' os on a
un androïde oreo avec une interface asus
then i 5
ça fonctionne plutôt bien vous avez
différentes applications dédiées
et asus calculatrice horloge contact
magnéto vous avez la météo le web
storage
enfin vous avez pas mal de petites
choses qui sont bien fichu d'un point de
vue navigation ça fonctionne bien on
retrouve un petit peu tous les basiques
qu'on a l'habitude d'avoir sous android
simple efficace claire entre quoi qui
fonctionne bien je trouve c'est la
reconnaissance pour déverrouiller la
reconnaissance du visage est extrêmement
rapide
le smartphone et la up il est verrouillé
je regarde il est roux tout de suite
c'est vraiment l'instantané et c'est
extrêmement rapide et à chaque fois ça
fonctionne extrêmement bien je
recommence hop
il est comme ça je me retourne c'est
vraiment bien pareil avec le capteur
d'empreintes digitales
je vais le mettre au peuple à face à
vous je pose sa déverrouille je pose sa
des jours où tout de suite c'est
vraiment rapide ça fonctionne bien d'un
côté comme de l'autre donc ça très bon
point côté audio il marche bien il
marche fort il est même plutôt très très
fort lorsque je mets une vidéo mais par
leur comme seule vraiment bien il ya
beaucoup de sons sache c'est vraiment
très très très salll tester sa également
au cas c'est pour voir si la sortie jack
est aussi convaincante est ce que le son
est très bien alors se faire sur la même
vidéo c'est fort ça marche bien je
patiente en des biens mais ça marche
plutôt pas mal ça va bien ouais au
niveau de l'eau de chasse est satisfait
ça marche plutôt bien que ce soit le cas
ce que ce soit directement le haut
parleur
le son est correct une fois de plus ce
que je vais recommander sur un appareil
comme ça lorsque vous brancher un casque
est bien évidemment de ne pas pousser le
son trop fort et sonne pas vous rend
complètement sourd ça c'est très
important et puis autre cas ce qui peut
être intéressant c'est de prendre
vraiment un casque qui va fermer un
casque actifs qui va analyser le son
extérieur qui va vous faire mais
vraiment pour vouziers pas une nuisance
sonore
ça vous évite de mettre le son à fond ça
vous évite de flinguer les oreilles et
ça croyez moi pour vraiment faire
attention
autre point qui est important c'est la
photo vidéo on va regarder si ce
smartphone fonctionne bien
s'il est satisfaisant mais déjà regardé
du point de vue de l'arrière voir s'il
est plutôt bien en termes de luminosité
en photo ou en vidéo
alors rien ici vous avez un double
capteur le premier
12 mégapixels avec une ouverture de f
1.8 et le deuxième c'est un grand-angle
120° une ouverture de f 2.2 ce sont des
capteurs sony et hynix 363 dual pixels
stabilisation optique à quatre axes vous
avez l'autofocus enfin un truc qui
franchement plutôt pas mal et à l'avant
ici vous avez un capteur de 8 mégapixels
avec une ouverture de f 2.0 vous avez
autre caméra ici un peu plus classique
ici vous allez avoir le grand angle qui
forcément va déformer c'est quelque
chose qu'on qu'on voit très bien on voit
une légère déformation vous avez un
grand panel de possibilités en termes de
résolution 4/3 en oublia pixels 9
mégapixels 8 mégapixels en 18 ans voilà
vous êtes un ami pas mal pas mal de
possibilités pour la vidéo et les mises
par défaut en face du en 1920 par 1080
mais vous pouvez aussi la mettre en 60
images par seconde alors la montée en
quelques usb directement en 3840 par
2160 en 30 images par seconde ou en 60
images par secondes vous à 10h dire que
pour eux soit qu'ils aient manuellement
soit désactivée soit laissé en
automatique c'est donc l'intelligence
artificielle qui va faire son boulot
pour mettre directement au le hdr au
moment opportun vous verrez que le
format 4/3 16/9 18/9 vous avez un mode
portrait que vous pouvez activer
désactiver à votre guise
un retardateur pour vos photos et bien
évidemment votre flash
vous avez aussi à votre confessionnelles
et d'accéder à quelques petits réglages
en termes de balance des blancs pour
régler avec plein de petites choses
ils pouvaient aussi exporter vos photos
au format raw autre point c'est sympa il
ya plusieurs filtres que vous pouvez
choisir le filtre négatif cela rise
enfin ya pas mal de petites de petites
possibilités
ce gadget c'est assez marrant ça marche
bien le plus simple c'est quand même de
rester seul mode automatique
après vous avez la possibilité d'avoir
la retouche d'image le mode manuel
professionnel vous avez aussi la super
résolution la possibilité de créer des
gifs animés
why not vous avez aussi du slow motion
en 240 images par seconde en full hd
autre point très intéressant vous avez
de la détection de scène vous avez 16
détection de scène grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle que ce
serait de la nourriture aussi à des
espaces verts des plantes de l'eau s'est
recouché soleil neige fleurs chiens
chats personnes texte trépied qr codes
enfin voilà paysages nocturnes
vous avez pas mal de possibilités c'est
tout l'intérêt d'avoir l'intelligence
artificielle qui avait vraiment vous
optimisez là dessus sur votre iphone 5 z
mais du côté des caméras de celle filles
vous avez aussi pas mal de choses vous
avez
ici le mode portrait vous avez un selphy
panoramique une petite chose à faire là
dessus c'est assez sympa là je peux vous
parler comme ça avec les fils serait que
je fais franchement hyper philippe école
est il donc de la photo et de la vidéo
directement sur cet asus iphone 5 z
on va aller voir ça en extérieur on va
les voir si la vidéo est intéressante
on va les voir si la photo est belle si
le rendu est bien situé grand-angle est
bien au niveau de la caméra arrière
on va essayer de voir si l'intelligence
artificielle fait vraiment bien son
boulot à voir aussi la caméra de saïfi
en photo ou en vidéo en fait un tour
complet on lâche sur l'extérieur il fait
relativement doux tout de suite donc ça
va pouvoir en profiter on va d'abord se
centrer sur la caméra arrière pour voir
si l'intelligence artificielle tu es
bien son boulot
si la stabilisation est bonne c'est le
rendu est plutôt bien et juste après on
va regarder du point de vue l'avant de
la camerata d'ivoire si c'est plutôt
cool
le rendu me paraît vraiment correct à
l'écran par rapport à ce que j'ai pu
voir sur d'autres smartphones ça pour le
coup c'est plutôt bientôt focus
fonctionne plutôt bien aussi
il réagit bien la définition est là pour
l'instant de ce que je vois à travers
l'image du smartphone plutôt satisfait
c'est vrai que je trouve que le rendu de
ce que je vois à l'écran
et quand même bluffant c'est vraiment
super joli on passe de temps sans les
caméras de celle fille de ce que je vois
je trouve que là aussi une fois de plus
la stabilisation est vraiment vraiment
correct parmi plusieurs smartphones que
j'ai pu tester ces derniers temps je
trouve que celui-ci deux points du
stabilisation est quand même nettement
meilleur nettement supérieur maintenant
je vais desrochers je regardais si
l'audio est aussi à la hauteur
ça c'est toujours un petit peu aussi le
point d'interrogation par rapport aux
placements des micros donc les
chanterelles simulant les conditions de
faible luminosité sur la caméra de cette
fille je trouve que ça rend plutôt bien
il est quand même une belle compensation
ça fonctionne bien le détail et pas
horrible par rapport à ce que j'ai pu
voir sur d'autres
logiciel donc là ça va aussi l'attention
la caméra avant là je ne vois pas
comment tu peux pas vous dire à vous de
me dire en commentaire ce que vous en
pensez
on est en conditions de faible
luminosité il n'y a pas d'éclairage ici
très peu d'arrivées de tours de lumière
donc si aucun endroit quand même assez
obscures bon alors verdict est ce que la
caméra de ce iphone 5 z
eh bien oui ou non et la loi pour
l'adapter sté je trouve qu'elle
fonctionne quand même plutôt pas mal ça
c'est plutôt un point positif la pâte
asus on la retrouve dans plein de petits
détails déjà dans les thèmes vous allez
avoir plein de thèmes pour revenir
personnaliser votre smartphone et avoir
une vraie expérience qui va être sympa
alors c'est le thème que vous allez
devoir acheter néanmoins tarif n'est pas
non plus énorme
si vous voulez avoir un environnement
qui vous plaît quelque chose qui est
sympa ne peut en faire plaisir pour les
tarifs qui sont pas non plus
complètement déconnant vous avez aussi
un gestionnaire du mobile qui vraiment
bien fait qui viennent votre temps
batteries restantes votre ram pouvait
analyser votre smartphone nettoyer la
mémoire il ya pas mal de petites options
ça c'est pareil c'est vraiment
intéressant autre chose qui est très
intéressante c'est le sel fille master
vous allez pouvoir aller encore plus
loin au niveau l'utilisation de
vaucelles fille par exemple faire ce
qu'on appelle les élit moggi alors les
animaux djc quoi je prends le hibou et
par la reconnaissance faciale
ça me permet d'animer mohib ou alors on
n'est pas quelque chose de si
performance qu'on va retrouver avec la
caméra trou d'aix d'apple mais ça
fonctionne quand même plutôt pas mal ça
me fait penser un peu aux arrêts moggi
qu'on peut retrouver directement chez
samsung fonctionne bien c'est rigolo là
donc je fais parler cette espèce de
petit tigre je retourne sur mon petit
hibou sympathique que je tourne la tête
à droite et à gauche ça marche bien j'en
ai pas mal comme ça que je peux faire
bouger je peux prendre ce joli petit
cheval par exemple je peux faire parler
et il dire bonjour à tous et monsieur
gros monsieur grain
vous êtes sur la chaîne youtube je suis
très heureux de vous accueillir
aujourd'hui je cligne de l'oeil droit je
fume de la gorge ou leur grade bon ça
nous permet de faire quelques petites
vidéos assez marrante s'est animée c'est
bien c'est pas aussi fluide que ce qu'on
peut retrouver sur l'iphone 10 c'est
normal en terme de technologie vos de la
caméra vous n'avez pas les mêmes
capteurs
par contre vous faire des petits trucs
un peu rigolo pour partager les vidéos
avec vos potes avec des têtes d'animaux
pourquoi pas c'est relativement sympa
vous avez pas mal de petites options
aussi dans le self et masters pour la
vidéo l'appareil photo le beauty life
colas diaporama ils vous ai montré les
animaux ji donc c'est vrai que d'un
point de vue photo vidéo je trouve qu'en
tout cas cet asus iphone 5 z il est
vraiment bien et pour un coût pour le
coup qui peuvent vraiment de se vanter
ce qu'ils ont marqué sur leur boîte
we love photo ils ont pu aussi rajouter
l'autre côté we love vidéo a pensé pour
un prochain packaging en tout cas serrée
ce point de vue là je trouve vraiment
bien réussi
c'est vraiment un smartphone qui est
optimisé pour l'intelligence
artificielle il va complètement optimisé
l'utilisation de votre batterie par
exemple en utilisant plus ou moins de
processeur en fonction de votre
utilisation du moment j'ai cherché à
optimiser le smartphone dans les
moindres détails c'est pareil je voulais
dit taylor pour la photo pour la vidéo
il va agir là dessus
autre point de détail il va adapter le
volume de la sonnerie vos smartphones
par rapport au bruit ambiant
donc si vous êtes dans un univers
extrêmement kahn fait pas de bruit comme
tout de suite maintenant ici la sonnerie
va être plutôt soft de douces des loges
dans un lieu très bruyant on peut
imaginer les transports en commun ou
dans la rue ou lors d'une soirée là ils
assurent des pleins gaz pour vraiment
vous puissiez entendre surtout des
petits détails mais qui mis bout à bout
font que ce smartphone est vraiment
intéressant l'autonomie je trouve pas
mal aussi vous avez une batterie 3300
millions erreurs c'est compliqué de vous
dire combien de temps vous allez pouvoir
l'utiliser avant une décharge complète
ça dépend bien évidemment de ce que vous
allez en faire si vous allez jouer à des
jeux qui sont très gourmands pas trop
gourmand sur celui ci sur le modèle z
en tout cas je peux le garder une
journée sans problème en utilisation
classique normal c'est à dire que c'est
pas tout le temps en train de jouer
c'est pas tout en dessus pas tout le
temps sans mes applications j'utilise de
temps en temps pour un des mails sur les
réseaux sociaux partagé avec le photo
vidéo je suis par le sauvage donc je
peux garder une journée sans aucun
problème autre détail vous avez du nfc
pour les paiements dématérialisés vous
avez un port jack ce vraiment tout à
l'heure dans le texte audio donc ça
c'est plutôt pas mal aussi vous avez du
bluetooth 5.0 la possibilité de m
deux cartes sim ou alors une carte sim
et une carte microsd je vous lisez vous
pouvez monter jusqu'à deux terrains de
stockage comment se positionne la gamme
iphone 5 en termes de prix le iphone 5
vous pouvez le trouver à 399,99 euros le
5 z à 499 99 euros et le 5 light à
299,99 euros
et évidemment ça dépend du vendeur donc
les prix peuvent toujours fluctuer un
peu plus haut ou un peu plus bas je vous
ai mis en tout cas des tarifs
intéressants en bas directement dans la
description ou alors au final est-ce que
ce smartphone est ce que ce asus z phone
5z est intéressant est intéressante
aussi un article est ce que ça vaut le
coup de l'acheter est ce que ça vaut pas
le coup de l'acheter alors je suis très
embêté parce que en règle générale sur
les smartphones étaient toujours dans la
balance les points positifs les points
négatifs qui fait une moyenne globale
vous dit pas là il est bien par rapport
à 6 par rapport à savoir alors celui là
franchement d'un point de vue esthétique
je trouve extrêmement bien réussi
extrêmement bien fait je ne suis pas
payé par as juste pour vous en parler
donc je peux dire ce que je veux même si
je suis payé de toute façon je m'en
cogne
je dis ce que j'ai à dire ça plaise
nombre donc je veux aider je trouve
extrêmement bien réussi d'un point de
vue esthétique
je trouve que le côté brillant ça donne
un aspect vraiment on a l'impression
avant un élément central au niveau du
capteur d'empreintes digitales
c'est vraiment bien fait c'est très joli
prouve aussi que la caméra est bien
positionné
ça on l'a déjà vu sur l'iphone disent
donc c'est pas une grande nouveauté
mais malgré tout ça marche bien le
l'encoche à l'avant ne me dérange
absolument pas une fois de plus que je
savais déjà vu sur l'iphone dit c'est
pareil c'est pas une grande nouveauté
si je devais trouver un point négatif
sur le design ça serait la petite barre
en bas une fois de plus c'est vraiment
pour aller chipoter je trouve que vous
avez quand même un grand écran de 6,2
pouces c'est effectivement pas dû aux
led c'est du lcd on est quand même sur
un smartphone qui n'est pas à 9 cents
voire 1000 euros donc bon on peut pas
avoir dû oled au tarif du lcd
on est sur un smartphone asus à moins de
500 euros donc une dalle ip est ce là
dessus ça ne dérange pas d'autant plus
qu'elle fait vraiment bien la faire donc
ça c'est bien autre point qui est très
intéressant c'est un photo et la vidéo
ça je vous le dis je suis bluffé je
trouve que c'est vraiment bien la
stabilisation est bien stabilisation
optique stabilisation logiciels s'est
extrêmement bien fait surtout avec moi
si vous habitudes de m
vidéo vous voyez que si tout de suite
c'est pas bien stabilisé sa part donne
pas on le voit directement là je trouve
que au contraire c'est vraiment bien
fait si vous voulez un smartphone qu'ils
soient bien stabilisé dans cette gamme
de tarifs
vous pouvez y aller les yeux fermés
d'autant plus que celui-ci la différence
que vous avez quel 5z et avec le 5
c'est processeur et la ram d'un côté
vous allez avoir un snapdragon 636 avec
4 gigas de ram de la côte est 1 845 avec
6 nigeria drame vous aurez toujours dans
un cas comme dans l'autre la
stabilisation optique donc ça c'est bien
après vous avez aussi un port jack puis
a trouvé bien l'audio marche bien le
smartphone se prend bien en main point
aussi qui est intéressant lorsque vous
jouez à des jeux votre parlerais la dont
vous pouvez le tenir comme ça ça va pas
vous poser des problèmes au niveau du
son vous n'avez pas bloquer les haut
parleurs avec vêtements ici et si vous
voulez jouer ensuite avec les prises
jack vous trouvez dans l'autre sens et
là vous avez votre porte jacques rault
et vous jouez dans ce sens là ça peut
non plus aucun problème pour
déverrouiller la reconnaissance marche
très bien sur son capteur arrière ou
alors avec la reconnaissance de visage
pour l'instant ce smartphone je lui vois
que des points positifs
voilà je ne vois pas de points négatifs
ça pourrait être mieux
ça pourrait être mieux effectivement
notamment avec une dalle oled mais
au-delà de ça pour l'utilisation lambda
utilisation courante je trouve qu'il est
extrêmement bien positionnée en rapport
qualité prix maintenant je me remets à
vous vous comment vous le trouvez de ce
que vous avez vu au travers de cette
vidéo de ce que vous avez peut-être pu
voir vous est-ce que vous avez vu dans
notre vidéo est ce que vous l'avez
essayé est-ce que vous en avez un scoop
d'aller acheter lorsque vous enlever
parce que vraiment ce smartphone tout de
suite je trouve pas de défauts mais
georges trouve pas de défauts je trouve
plutôt pas mal donc dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas a directement aux
commentaires qu'on puisse comme ça en
discuter merci en tout cas d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je vous invite comme
d'hab abcd jolie pousse des lights on
s'abonne en reste connecté il ya plein
de choses qui vont arriver dans les
temps à venir plein de surprises des
cadeaux des actuels excluent énormément
de choses donc restez connectés d'ici là
soyez sages n'oubliez pas je vous
embrasse toutes les meilleures et à très
bientôt
ciao
[Musique]